good evening I'm Alexander Rose I'm the
executive director here at long now
thank you all for making it out on a
rainy night the rain we need so badly
here as many of you know before these
talks we often screen what we call a
long short a short film about long term
thinking or at least that exemplifies
long term thinking the one that we've
chosen this week while we still let some
of the stragglers get in is a
particularly long long short it's eight
minutes instead of our usual three
minutes but it's it's a film that takes
place over about eight seconds slowed
way down to epic proportions
enjoy
you
you realize that's what you look like to
your laptop if George is right
good evening I'm Stuart brand from the
long now foundation this is a holy book
George Tyson's trans Cathedral in the
beginning was the number and the number
was told not to just being something the
number was told to do something 60 years
ago that happened and that brings us
here I just learned that the entire
entering class at UC Berkeley next year
7,000 strong are all getting this book
to read over the summer and then they
are expected to know it next year as
they go to school not a bad use of a
holy book and the author's total dream
special printing 7,000 copies just for
students they will tell everybody
George Tyson is here to speak to you
George thank you
[Applause]
and what they forgot was that I went to
University of California for three
months and dropped out because I
couldn't stand things like assigned
reading this is sort of the irony of
fate is that now I you know I've
produced the assigned reading that I ran
away from so thank you all for coming
out it's a fabulous venue to be here my
opening slide is is in honor of one of
the long now found her tonight the Danny
Hillis who really is one of people who
brings us all here and he said it and
why he what I'm gonna say in an hour he
said in one slide that memory locations
are just wires turned sideways in time
and the converse is true also so the
story I'm going to tell you is an old
story it's been told many times and it
was sometimes with a bit of warning and
I think this warning from 1679 from you
know 350 years ago is worth listening to
today so this is the story of friar
bacon who wanted to build what we now
call an AI so he was trying to build
Google the the the brass had that knows
everything and can answer all questions
so friar Bunge and fire bacon with great
study and pain so framed a head of brass
that in the inward parts thereof there
was all things like in a natural man's
head this being done they were is far
from perfection of the work as they were
before that at last they concluded to
raise a spirit and to know of him that
which they could not attain to by their
own studies so that was exactly what
happened in the field of AI they kept
building these machines and they just
weren't intelligent so we keep looking
for the spirit and they were so
exhausted after all this work that they
said we're gonna go take a nap and they
left their assistant their graduate
student miles to watch the head while
they took a nap
and miles started playing on his iPhone
and listening to music and wasn't really
paying attention and and then the head
said time is that miles hearing it to
speak no more thought his master would
be angry if he waked him for that and
therefore he let them both sleep and
began to mock the head in this matter
Val brazen-faced head hath my master
took all this pains about thee and now
dust thou requite him with two words
time is had he watched with a lawyer as
long as he hath watched with thee he
would have given him more and better
words so lawyers have been the subject
of ridicule for a long time then miles
talked and song and just fooled around
til another half-hour is gone then the
brazen head spake again these words time
is passed and there with fell down and
presently followed a terrible noise with
strange flashes of fire so that miles
was half dead with fear at this noise
the two friars awake and wandered to see
the whole room so full of smoke but that
being vanished they might perceive the
brazen head broken and lying on the
ground and that's what could happen that
we keep waiting for a I and but it's so
entertaining we get so caught up in all
the entertainment that it it could
happen it could be over it would be over
a I did happen it would be over just
like that there would just be a fraction
of a second and time was so that's I'm
not going to talk about that the some
people call this the singularity and in
any digital universe it's is bounded by
two singularities there's a singularity
at T equals zero and there's a
singularity at T equals infinity and the
T equals infinity we can't predict and
I'm interested in what happened at the
first singularity at the moment
zero and I'm so I'm gonna tell you that
story that in a way is sort of the same
time span as my own life I came to
California with Esther my sister Esther
who's in the audience here in 1955 and
the only way to come to California is in
a convertible on route 66 with my dad
Freeman and my mother Verena who took
these marvelous black-and-white pictures
and we arrived in San Francisco which
looked like this Fisherman's Wharf was
still there and if you were a kid from
New Jersey this this was the Promised
Land this was it there was no how could
anyone go back to New Jersey after San
Francisco but my father took us back to
New Jersey so I did my best to come back
to California and several people I'm
only gonna mention three old-school
Californians were great so heroes and
mentors of my life the first being David
Brower here this photograph when he came
he led the 10th Mountain Division
Mountain troops and they came on skis
over the Alps and liberated the Po
Valley in Italy and this picture of him
was taken playing a piano they had been
left by the retreating Germans and
Norman Clyde who was a real mountain man
Norma Clyde did he over half of the
first descents in the Sierra Nevada were
done by Norman Clyde we'd been a
schoolteacher and just left went to live
in the mountains so I met Norman through
my mother I met David Brower and through
David Brower I met Norman Clyde and I
wanted to be Norman Clyde and then I
didn't meet Stuart brand but I was
tremendously influenced by his whole
earth catalogue so I I sort of put
Stuart brand and Norman Clyde and David
Brower together and that was me I wanted
to be that
and took off ended up going to Canada to
work on boats it's me on the far left
and in Canada there were kayaks on the
money the money had kayaks on it so it
to me I was so happy in Canada oh great
yeah and one of the resources referenced
in the whole earth catalogue was this
Smithsonian study of the bark canoes and
skinned boats that became my Bible the
polar catalog told you where you could
order it for two dollars and
seventy-five cents from the Government
Printing Office and I made it my mission
to essentially do with kayaks what
stewart is now trying to do with extinct
animals to sort of decode their DNA and
bring them back in in modern form and i
did a lot of that that's in vancouver
canada so this is the sort of DNA you
have of these ancient kayaks that went
extinct at the time of the Russians
arrived and I would try and replicate
them and that brought me into this
longtime skill with people in the
Aleutian Islands had been living that
life that in that same ecological regime
for ten thousand years some of the
villages are continuously occupied for
ten thousand years which is a record as
far as we know in North America and I
sort of tried to continue that on into
what I thought the future would bring
the with mixed success but but
interesting and they will do all that
because I lived in a tree house 95 feet
up in that Douglas fir tree at the top
and that in a way was like living in a
clock the tree trees have a completely
different sense of time that you know
they they grow a new ring every year so
you're living in this sort of
thousand-year clock so when when Stuart
and Danny and Kevin and and a few other
people started trying to build the lawn
now clock I immediately became
fascinated with that and it resonated
that's the early version of the clock so
that was the analog clock and I'm going
to tell you about this birth of this
digital clock that we all sort of live
in now so this is the moment the sort of
the T equals zero the Big Bang of this
address space in which we all live and
that so that is 1,000 bits of memory
that's on the glass face of a what was
called a Williams tube they actually saw
a picture of one today that's a Stanford
and and what we do all day now where
we're tapping on this glass of our
smartphone or our computer screen that's
the direct ancestor of this that these
spots were actually spots of capacitance
the pattern of electric charge on the
face of an analog World War 2 era tube
that was used to store digital
information that could be recalled at
the speed of light and that was sort of
the moment of transition between the
analog world and this new digital world
that so it consumes us today and the
person who did more than anyone else to
actually with his own hands make this
transition happen was Julian Heim Lee
Bigelow who interestingly enough would
be 100 would be his 100th birthday today
March 19th 1913 so we owe him tremendous
gratitude for what
[Applause]
what he did he was a great scientist and
a great mathematician but his fatal flaw
was that he was also an engineer and if
if you are an engineer at that time you
sort of demeaned your your status among
the academics which which was sad and
injustice but his so his daughter Alice
who was Esther's best friend explained
how the age of three while staying with
an aunt he found a screwdriver and
removed all the doorknobs and put them
in a big pile and it took him a really
long time to put all these doorknobs
back and that was Julianne if you just
if you went into Julien's house there
were pieces of his airplane in his car
in the living room he just always had
things taken apart and as when I was a
child living with all these great
theoretical physicists Julian was my
hero because he was the guy who really
took things apart and put them back
together so he had the remarkable
fortune just these things are always
twists of fate to end up working in
world war ii with Norbert Wiener who
here is seen in World War one and they
worked together
no ravine er had been kicked out of the
army for inability to fire a rifle or
stay on a horse and but when world war
ii came along he really wanted to help
so he he took on the most difficult
problem in World War two which was
hitting moving airplanes with
anti-aircraft fire because you have you
have minutes before the shell gets to
where the airplane was and you don't hit
it so you're trying to predict where
will the airplane be in a few minutes
and the pilot is is trying to be
somewhere else and he and Julian just
ignored all the critics and went full
speed on this problem and this led us to
the cybernetic world and there's George
stibitz who was their supervisor you
know complaining that they must be
cheating somehow this thing is so
uncanny they built this predictor that
they would test by moving a spot of
light at random in a room and they would
try and target it and they were what
they were doing was they were taking the
path
and reversing it in time and with a
bunch of clever very very clever
algorithms and doing a pretty good job
so Julian wrote this up in his maxims
for ideal prognosticators that there are
actually 15 of them and most of these
the fact that you have all in your
pockets these micro processors that work
for billions of cycles without any
errors are largely results of his maxims
for ideal prognostic years of correct
avoiding and correcting error and noise
and so that the main one being that the
if noise has ever be filtered from
signal it must be done at the earliest
possible stage rather than after the two
are tangled with other noises and
signals for the same reason that
repeater stations are used on a signal
line rather than filters and amplifiers
at the end and that's really the
principle of modern digital computers is
a realization of that you're moving all
these bits so in nineteen they were all
these reports which unfortunately were
classified in secret making a very good
point that that in transmitting
information the transmission of a single
fixed item of information is of no
communicative value we must have a
repertory of possible messages and over
this repertory measure determining the
probability of these messages and that
in two sentences is Shannon Claude
Shannon's mathematical theory of
information which which came directly
from this so then in 1943 during still
during the war Norbert Wiener in Bigelow
write this paper behavior purpose and
teleology very far thinking paper in
sort of plain english language and that
becomes the basis of they've decided to
form a group the teleological society
and that name scares people so they
coined a new name cybernetic so that
becomes the cybernetics group and the
cybernetics movement and that of course
is what captured Stuart brand so that's
that's how we all got here
is through through that problem of
trying to predict the path of an
airplane this is a great book by the way
it's a it's a rolling stone article was
I it was that the first Rolling Stone
article made into a book I think I think
so and so Norbert wieners boss in World
War one was Oswald Veblen who so much
more mathematics was done in these
computing shacks at the army proving
ground of over one and was done in all
the great universities of Europe and
America that Oswald Veblen decided how
can we keep this sort of Los Alamos
spirit going and the result was the
Institute for Advanced Study in
Princeton a place where people could
just come and work on whatever they
interest in the year I was there there
was one person who spent the whole year
studying medieval names for badgers and
and the first director was Abraham
Flexner who believed if you let people
work on all these useless things
occasionally something useful will come
out of it and and he was right and they
happened to be they were funded by
Jewish merchants at a time when when it
was very difficult for Jewish professors
to get faculty positions and so they
went out of their way to bring Jewish
academics from Europe to safety in
America and they saved many many lives
and this is sort of a score sheet of who
they can hire in 1939 and all these
people like Paul Erdos Kurt gödel their
lives were saved by these very small you
know stipends they got to come to
Princeton to safety so here Princeton
became this little Conclave of Eastern
Europeans this is a drinking party in
the 1930s there are all Hungarians from
Budapest except HP Robertson and Amelia
vikner from from Madison Wisconsin
Edward Teller Johnny von Neumann so HP
Robertson then into that mix
as a student and actually took particle
physics from HP robertson is a young
british student Alan Turing shows up in
September 1936 in that among all his
people and he brings with him the proofs
for this paper on digital computing on
computable numbers trying to solve this
thing called the insight ohms problem
which is massacred technically is the
question whether by looking at a string
of code can you is there any systematic
way to tell whether that string of
symbols is ax is a provable formula or
not and that can be translated
computationally sort of by by looking at
a string of code can you tell whether
it's a virus or a good or bad and the
answer was no you can't but to get to
that answer he invented this abstract
idea we now call a Turing machine which
is a digital computer that reads a tape
and has all the time in the world and
all the tape and the can always call for
more tape and the one of the conclusions
is that if you build one of these Turing
machines that's the only one you need
and everything else can be done with
codes so that's early origins of
software and that had profound its
course proved that the in sightings
problem was not solvable and it also
proved that the digital universe will
always be no matter how one country or
one company or government tries to
control it it will never it will always
be a wilderness not a it even if fully
deterministic universe is unpredictable
which sounds sort of contradictory but
it's not it's very closely related to
what what Kurt gödel did that when
Tory's paper was published he writes
back to his mother in England very
unhappy because only two requests for
copies came in only two people were
interested enough to write and ask for a
copy and it seems like one of these
papers that would have no interest
outside of the pure logicians but then
World War two came along and the problem
became very real of
coding digitally encrypted German
messages to their u-boat fleet and
ballon Turing was brought in to work on
that made this statement that your next
speaker Nicholas Negroponte II has
something to say about that being
digital should be more interests than
being electronic but being digital and
electronic would be really interesting
especially if you're trying to decode
these German messages so that during the
war the group partly involving Turing
built by an engineer Thomas flowers
built this machine called Colossus which
was a real Turing machine that could
imitate any number of other possible
machines including they could use it to
try and imitate the state of the German
machine they didn't know the state of
that was encoding these messages and it
worked they actually were able to get a
important fraction of these messages
decoded within 24 hours and we probably
would not have won World War two without
that and in his paper on the Turing
machine Allen explains that he makes
time discrete that time instead of being
our kind of time that's continuous time
becomes just a series of steps and the
problem is that he calls it a clock and
time and it really isn't a clock in our
sense of a clock that measures time it's
just clock in the sense of a call of a
escapement that just measures events and
at that time the British were way ahead
in computing Alan Turing who was a
long-distance runner and then suddenly
the Americans led by Johnny von Neumann
they start trying to catch up because
they have their own problem trying to
build nuclear weapons and Los Alamos so
that the British are over in brecci Park
working on decoding signals and the
Americans are trying to build bombs and
those are the two forces driving the
computing world it was for this arms
race between the two sides so this is
the 3d explosion 25 microsecond 25
millionths of a second after detonation
so they're doing
very long in the MOOC film we saw I
think that was compressed 60 to 1 here
they were doing calculations that would
run six weeks to calculate what happened
in a hundred shakes which is one
millionth of a second so that's that's
more like 60 trillion to one compression
of time so this is our American machine
to Eenie AK which funnyman got to see
and work with and and it absolutely
captured him and he essentially took all
their ideas phenomen rich dick Fineman
Stan um who were at Los Alamos and they
had so much fun so my father always says
that when when Oppenheimer said the
physicists have known sin he wasn't they
weren't he wasn't speaking in a moral
sense he was speaking the sense that
they they had so much fun building this
bomb that was the sin not he wasn't
talking about using it so finally asked
what's next I'm thinking about something
much more important than bombs I'm
thinking about computers he saw clearly
this would be the next big thing
all these most of people I'm talking
about died unfortunately very young so
but not even takes puts all the eniac
ideas together he had a gift for just
grabbing ideas and making them coherent
writes this report that actually Herman
goldstine puts only his name on which
rightfully really really annoyed the
ENIAC people publishes it and gets all
the credit and so he lays out how to
build a effectively a modern digital
computer how to build an adder how to do
all this binary arithmetic and then if
you look closely he gives us this what
we call the von Neumann architecture but
it should should be named something else
it's the central processor the central
control unit a memory which is your your
internal memory a recording medium input
output and then time so where does time
come in there's a delay of T seconds and
he's saying well the T the clock cycle
will be order of a millionth of a second
something will happen every millionth a
million times a second so you have these
pulses but again they're not measuring
time they're just measuring the next
step in the number so they he decides to
build this machine
nobody will build it for him he's
annoyed with how slow everything is so
he says I'm gonna build it ourselves
they have their first meeting and at
that meeting he lays the out the
commandment that words coding the orders
are handled in the memory just like
numbers and that's what Stewart
mentioned in the introduction that this
was this up until this time numbers were
used to mean things like 6 apples 7
oranges so and now these codes what we
call the order codes whereas there were
numbers that were allowed to do things
and Julian Bigelow was we wrote very
explicitly how they even though we write
the programs we don't know what these
numbers are gonna do once we let them
loose inside the memory of this machine
and you saw that all coming and that's
the sort of fundamental transition into
a very new world and that was Alan
Turing's idea because in his original
mathematical description of the Turing
machine he allows numbers to actually
become machines it's yeah it was just
what you do when you you know you buy
your iPhone and then you download apps
you're just downloading numbers that are
the particular machine you want for
whatever you're in historians have
argued endlessly but you know did von
Newman take those ideas from Turing some
people say oh he didn't even read
Turing's paper he was so brilliant and
it's not true if you go to Von Neumanns
library the library of the computing
project this is the the all the
Proceedings of London mathematical
scientists elf when their cells you have
to turn a crank because nobody goes
there anymore to open the shelves and
nearly all are and they're all unopened
new like nobody's read them since 1930
30s except one volume the volume with
Turing's paper and it's completely loose
and torn apart from being read so many
times by the engineers who all told me
that this
surviving ones who I interviewed said oh
yeah nothin when we got hired Bigelow
said read this paper we're building
Turing's machine and then von neumann
himself said let the whole world outs
outside world consists of a long paper
tape that's that's his tribute to Turing
now you didn't have an infinite amount
of tape a Turing machine could compute
anything but it might take the half the
age of the universe to do it and they
were we're trying to win the Cold War so
they wanted to do it faster so how would
they get fast memory and RCA promised
them phenomen went to RCA who were the
wizards and electronics oh yes we will
build you this tube and we'll call it
ass electron and it was to use a word to
Esther coin the vaporware of the 1950s
they they were promising effectively a
USB memory stick a stick that you just
plug that into your computer and it's
four kilobytes of memory and it's fast
and it never fails and when they
actually got the only computer that used
these was the Thor and the Johnny a cat
ran and they ran a hundred thousand an
hour's mean time between failures so
this electron worked great just RCA
would not support it so they never they
never got enough to finish their
computer but it was a great idea and
this was the date so he had beautiful
advertising literature for a product
that did not exist and it was the work
of Yann Reichman and Vladimir Zworykin a
Russian you notice that most of the
people who gave America all this
wonderful stuff were Europeans
particularly Eastern Europeans who would
have trouble getting visas today so
they're trying to build this at the
Institute for Advanced Study where they
only are you know there's art historians
and and Greek people studying Greek
epigraphy and medieval names for badgers
and so on they're trying to build a
computer and they and so it's May 1946
before they end of May they finally
spend $4 for electrical work that's the
beginning of and the next day so it's
wonderful when you go through archives
and you find these things and next day
they hire Julian Bigelow so the the von
Neumann asks
Revere who can I get to build this thing
he was trying to hire the Uni act people
but they said no there's a new Weiner
had one word which was Bigelow and and
he was hired and that's she said for the
first five or six months we were crowded
into the boiler room they put him down
in the second basement with a few work
benches we set out there was not even an
office for me to go to and hide and
think about circuit logic without having
people walking over my desk and crawling
all over me and that if you go find that
basement room next to the boiler room
now actually not now they had to expand
but five years ago if you went there
that was the main server room for the
Institute so they they won and they so
Julian's job was not only to build a
machine but to publish clear and
coherent progress reports every step of
the way and these reports went to dozens
of other laboratories copying this
machine and that's really how we ended
up in this world where we're all the
machines have this sort of common
ancestor they had this beautiful
headquarters but it was full already
full of scholars Einstein was the second
pueblan was the first professor hired
then Einstein then von Neumann who's
next to the common room but if you look
at who we got or the second floor who's
above the Neyman is dr. girdle kurt
gödel who was even more sort of
disconnected than alan turing from the
real world and yet this whole address
space in which we live in many ways is
girdle's idea that gödel who was who was
great friends with Einstein wrote his
great paper that the forth first thing
he does his credit von Neumann who'd
been working in the same field of logic
so when they're wondering where they can
put these computer people to write start
writing these reports they heard that
goodwill had an office for a secretary
but he didn't want a secretary he didn't
want somebody waiting for him to write
so that room was empty and that's where
the the computer people started and
wrote
reports and what Goodell had done in his
great paper that proved the
incompleteness of mathematics he did it
with a sort of Turing machine like trick
where he allowed logical concepts to be
encoded as strings of numbers and then
those strings of numbers he was an
Austin who has suffered terrible
numerical bureaucracy in Vienna so he
was familiar with this and and the the
these strings of numerical code were
then given numerical addresses that
could be manipulated with arithmetic and
then in this tortured way he proved this
result that changed all of science and
math and but he did it with this idea of
addressing and that's what phenomen did
when he built this machine the
architecture and the way then Bigelow
realized it if you read that script it's
led a word forty a string of forty
binary digits which is how it became
known as a word they didn't have bits
yet be two orders each order is a
command and an address so he was using
this sort of girdle trick and all our
computing today is just taken for
granted it still works that way we use
commands and addresses Neil Stevenson
would say in the beginning was the
command line so this world that
surrounds us it's not you know I'm not
talking about the first computer this is
actually the eleventh electronic
computer not the first at all but it's
the origins of this address space which
is the important thing that's how the
internet and everything we do digitally
today works is because every string of
bits has a numerical address and by
referencing those addresses you can
manipulate those underlying bits and it
started in this machine where if you see
those things that look like coffee cans
each of those is one of those cathode
ray tubes with a 32 by 32 a thousand
bits in each tube and there's 40 of
those and and Julian Bigelow is genius
as an engineer was to build that thing
just like an engine if you look
it's a v40 overhead valve engine because
he was a engine mechanic and it runs
numbers at it at a terrific speed and so
it was brilliant we take it all for
granted that that's just micro
processors all they are the way they are
but they are the way they are because
they are all exact functional copies of
that once you got that machine running
and you got you wrote code to write on
that machine we were stuck we've just
been caught in this loop it's like the
origins of DNA that we could do genetic
code in all kinds of other ways but once
it was set three billion years ago
that's what we got so he Julian and
Johnny had a gift for bringing in all
these great people to work on this who
then distributed it other places and
people to write the code but where would
they live there was no where to look
Princeton was still a hard place to live
so Julian he gave a problem he solved it
he went up to upstate New York and
bought eleven of these worth surplus
mind barracks from an iron mine and
sawed them in half and brought them to
Princeton on railroad cars and built a
housing project that's been transformed
but it's still there and then endless
debates with the director where to put
these people and here he's saying the
only real useable space in our basement
is that adjoining the men's lavatory to
which you're most heartily welcome and
even that annoyed the historian so this
is Benjamin Merritt who's actually the
model for Indiana Jones he was a
paleontologist I have learned with some
dismay the group of electronic experts
has moved into half of the basement of
our wing the historians wing of the
Institute hope they move mathematicians
in our wing over my dead body and yours
and you have to remember that the and
Elias Lowe was a was a Greek classical
Greek scholar who's actually grandson is
Mayor of London and he the vision of
Abraham Flexner was this Institute was
where the mathematicians and the
historians and the music scholars and
the artists
we're all going to eat meals together
and and live together and play lawn
bowling you know lawn bowls together and
if you go there even today it is so
fragmented the strength theorists don't
sit with the solid state physicists and
the astronomers won't sit with the
biologists and the and the medieval
historians don't sit with a class it's
completely like a high school they just
have differentiated and then and then
you throw computer geeks into that mix
that there's Gerald Estrin whose
daughters Deborah Estrin and Judy estrin
are big players sort of brought us Cisco
and a bunch of other things that make
our world work today general he then
went to Israel built the first computer
the Y Zack at the Weitzman Institute and
now the directors complain because of
the the mathematicians are complaining
about the computer people drinking not
only drinking too much tea but putting
too much sugar in their tea
they've been especially unfair in a
matter of sugar it'd be better for the
computer people to come up to fault hall
at the end of the day at five o'clock in
the afternoon and have their tea here
under proper supervision but the
computer people got their revenge if if
you are a classical historian or someone
at the Institute today and you're
working late on some paper and at 11
o'clock at night you want to your coffee
the only place you can get it is the
shamone building built by a Hungarian
computer programmer so now the the shoe
is on the other foot and all the funding
have used to all areas on their board
that most of their funding comes from
the software business so what they were
complaining so much about turned out to
be their salvation and they've done very
well by it so everything had to be done
from the bottom up so this is an and or
gate something we take completely for
granted today but somebody had to sit
down with a piece of paper say okay this
is going to be our and or
gate and they're doing all this with
analog vacuum tubes with don't really
behave in a in a purely binary way
looking you think I guess how you
construct these communicating banks of
cells that become shift registers wiring
down somebody has to actually wire all
this put it together so that's the first
shift register which is how the actual
arithmetic gets done is very simple can
be done by just shifting digits but
bigelow in what he had learned in the
war made this hundred percent reliable
by instead of shifting the bits directly
from that one row of tubes to the next
they go up into the upper row and only
when the upper row says okay all the
bits are here everything's okay then you
can all go down so they're never the
which is again why how the internet
works because the bits are just flying
all over the network on Ethernet they're
colliding they're being lost along the
way but everything is checked and until
and if you didn't get the message
completely you ask for those bits again
and the very structure of the computer
incorporates that that's you notice
that's shifting register number seven so
they went through six iterations before
they came to one that they decided to
keep and replicated it and joy in higher
high school kids to do most of the
actual physical machine work of building
this machine and here's Andrew booth
explaining that this computer did not
have what we now call a clock speed
everyone snow is always your processor
you know 1.2 gigahertz or 1.4 this
Bigelow machine had no clock speed you
could make it go as fast as you wanted
or as slow as you wanted and and that
was a very important principle in it and
it worked very well the problem was the
memory they had this basically there
isn't taking it ready to go but still no
memory from RCA nice brochures but no
select ron's it had a few prototypes
there's actually a 256 bits electron but
they they needed you know
40 of them to build the machine so they
started to julienne so I'll make some
high-speed memory he builds this thing
which is magnetic wire on bicycle wheels
and they were able to get 90 thousand
bits per second in but they want they
want to be able to test their software
and actually so this would sort of be a
simulated memory on effectively like a
ram disk and so that's a picture that's
a 40 bit word and that you know that's
the dividing line between analog and
digital it was very very fuzzy but they
got they got that to work but then in
the end they heard that Tom Kilburn and
Frederick Williams in England had got a
fully electronic digital memory working
that we now call the Williams to the
Institute got their reports at that time
it was still just after the war so
everyone was freely exchanging all
information with no patents or anything
so I mean Freddie Williams had got this
to kilobit storage on the face of a
cathode ray tube julian immediately took
the you know a ship to England and spent
two weeks at their lab and brought back
this was the lab in Manchester the first
stored-program computer to get running
they brought that idea back Jim Palmer
een got it to work using just straight
off-the-shelf or surplus oscilloscope
tubes but very very clever hack putting
an amplifier right in the face of the
tube sort on Bigelow's principle you
didn't want to send the signal very far
cause you'd get noise Julian tell you
that these memory tubes were the world's
most sophisticated sensitive detector of
electromagnetic noise so the real
problem with them was that they did
remember if any stray cosmic ray or
something hit him they remembered it and
so that's the difference you know we now
take for granted until there's between a
0 and a 1 the difference between a dash
and a dot was this very fuzzy
distinction that you had 3/4 of a
millionth of a second to make that
distinction and then they had what they
called a clock but it was not a clock
you know
sense of regulating the speed of the
computer it was a clock just in order to
lay out the the pattern of spots on that
tube and then the memory itself was
independent of time every tube had its
own logbook recording its flaws the
first line of defense if a tube stopped
working because all your all your
calculations would end if one tube went
bad was to take it out and hit it and
put it back and that's the fact that
they logged these tubes and took these
pictures that's why we have it's like
the early plates from of when you see an
O supernovae and you want to go back and
look on the old plates that glass plates
we have these pictures of the birth the
dawn for the first light of the digital
universe are in these so here you see
this brilliant architecture this machine
that is three dimensional all most
computers before and particularly since
are laid out flat or lay out like the
map of New York City with everything on
a flat circuit board or a plane but
Julian knew that short connection paths
were necessary like a Cray was actually
three dimensional that so he built it
like the way your cerebral flat cerebral
cortex is folded into your skull so all
the electronics was folded up and so
made it horrible to maintain but very
compact and very fast and and easy to
cool cuz all the cooling ran through the
central core and Johnny who so it became
known as the von Neumann machine but
phenomen himself would he would be
horrified if he brought him today and
said look at all these computers we know
we call him von Oy you see you guys are
still building copies of that lousy
machine that we you know we just built
to solve one problem we thought in 1948
you replace it with something else and
and Willis where who's still alive
was it ran Dre I really summed it up
that these were not fun no his ideas but
he put them together he was in the right
place at the right time with the right
connections with the right idea setting
aside the hassle that will
they'd never be resolved as to whose
ideas they really were there's a lot of
other people who deserve the credit but
one of the main reasons we ended up in
this von Niemann universe was because
unknown to many others who would have
been slightly horrified he was privately
consulting on private retainer for IBM
during the whole time so by modern
standards that was a little bit
unethical an IBM sent a limousine every
month and they brought him up to
Poughkeepsie and he told them everything
and they wind a diner for two days and
then drove him back to Princeton and you
know they got all the now to his credit
nothing was patented and it was all
freely distributed to all the other
companies too but he he wanted to push
it as fast as possible and he was able
to get people like Julian Bigelow and
Herman goldstine who was the director in
the project and they hated each other it
couldn't work together at all but
through von Neumann had this ability to
get everybody cooperating including his
boss at the Institute Robert Oppenheimer
who was a really pretty two-faced guy I
mean Oppenheimer who's gone down in
history is opposing the hydrogen bomb
and being a martyr to his principles and
so on but he was he was at that time
pushing full-speed for it too and the
computer was really it was built in
order to answer the hydrogen bomb
feasibility question this is you know
does this date mean anything August 9th
1945 okay that's the day we dropped the
second bomb the first bomb you could
argue there was a reason for it but
there was no reason for the second bomb
on Nagasaki so the day they dropped the
bomb on Nagasaki this telegram from
Edward Teller to von Neumann saying Stan
and Nick who've been embedded at the
Institute in secret developing
algorithms for hydrogen bomb calculators
now they can act in the open is coming
from Los Alamos so there's Stanley lamb
who came out from Poland for $300 they
got stanlon out of Warsaw and he was
trying to prove that Edward tellers idea
would not work and in thinking about why
it wouldn't work he of course thought of
a way that
it could work and so we ended up with
with who lands the UM teller invention
which was the first thing that was
really designed in a computer like sort
of most of our products today are
designed in and Kevin's written a lot
about that about how could you know
computers are the source of all these
new designs if it was the first thing
designed in the computer and a
tremendous success you couldn't test it
experimentally a lot of that work was
done by Nick metropolis Greek who
invented the Stanwell am who invented
the Monte Carlo method but Nicholas who
just sort of the hard work of getting it
really operating and all at early coding
and the Montecarlo problems was done by
Clary funnyman Johnny's second wife who
he met at the casino in Monte Carlo he
had he had developed a system for
roulette and it had failed and he had no
money left and went to the bar and she
remembered him from childhood Bhupesh
and bought him a drink and the rest was
history but it but the one I found that
and in in her letters that her
stepdaughter gave me I mean I couldn't
believe it that they actually met in
Monte Carlo so if you look at what they
did with that machine and now what they
had they built this address matrix that
was 32 each to had 32 bits by 32 bits so
that's like four 8x8 chess boards and
then they stacked 40 of them up so you
can visualize in address space it's 32
by 32 by 40 and in modern language
that's five kilobytes of memory that's
all they had that's not even that's one
half second of a mp3 audio very very
very little but in that memory in the
few years they ran that machine for
maybe 1951 to 1957 they worked on these
five main problems that computationally
are similar but on very different time
scale so that central line in numbers is
seconds it's 26 orders of magnitude in
time from 10 to the minus 8 seconds
which is the lifetime of a
neutron in a chain reaction all the way
to 10 to the 17th seconds which is the
lifetime of the Sun so they picked these
five another site you know he wanted the
most difficult problems so first they
did nuclear explosions which was who
their customer was paying them for that
money it was their deal with a devil the
military said you know we you give us
you design us the weapons and you get
the computer and and the deal was if you
know if you know tell us how to use the
bombs we won't tell you how to do the
science and that was the deal males
almost and if you really want the short
explanation why didn't Homer get in so
much trouble it's because he broke that
deal he started trying to tell the
military how to use the bombs and that's
when they sort of said no more up and I
really gotta get rid of this guy cuz
because he's broke that that rule so
they worked on the nuclear explosions
then they worked on the question of
shockwaves over the timescale of seconds
what happens after the bomb goes off
very nonlinear and then in the middle
was meteorology they worked on weather
prediction which seemed impossibly
ambitious at that time but they were
very successful I was successful that by
1954 they were getting a twenty that the
first 24-hour prediction in less than 24
hours of computing time and and from
then on it's just progressed so now we
really get a pretty good three to five
day prediction and then phenomen brought
in a crazy Italian name Italian
Norwegian name Nils baricelli who worked
on models of biological evolution over a
time scale of years and centuries and
then he brought in Martin sorts child
who worked on the evolution of stars and
galaxies these five problems on this
different time scales and if you look at
where we are we live in this world we're
like the fastest thing you can perceive
it's a blink of an eye a third of a
second and the longest might be your
whole life of 90 years and if you find
the middle
it's a working day of eight hours and I
and whether that's a I still don't
understand why is it that we appear to
be sort of in the middle of this scale
of time the sort of what we can pay
attention to for a whole day is exactly
in half of what's observable and what
computers did was greatly enlarge our
ability to work in these very short
periods of time and they also enlarged
our ability to look at very long period
I mean I think that's the hope for the
future that that computers not only by
being very fast could design these
terrible weapons and so on but can do
things like model climate and look at
bring back long extinct species and and
sort of change the time scale at which
we operate fun oi Minh was very
interested as all this or seems to be a
disease of aging physicists have become
interested in the origins of life and I
mean it happened to most of them and it
never seems to go the other way you ever
met a biologist who became interested in
physics and all they know it goes the
other way so no I mean had his own
careers about gist but he brought in
Nils baricelli
who also couldn't get a visa because the
Italians said no you got to apply
through the Norwegian Embassy and the
Norwegians said no you got to apply
through the Italian embassy and it took
two years to sort that mess out so he
was two years late getting to America
and immediately he gets there sort of
the day they're running all these
hydrogen bomb problems and they let him
have the machine late at night after the
Los Alamos people have left and he
starts running these he's trying to
create numerical organisms within this
the first person to I know to really
talk about a digital universe publishes
his first paper in Italian if it's that
easy to create living origins why don't
you create a few yourself so he tries
and so he's doing a very different thing
he's not running what we call algorithms
he's not running trying to solve
problems he's allowing these bits to
operate like organisms to
purdue's to suffer mutations to compete
against each other within this five
kilobyte little universe and what you
know Turing showed us was that one
machine could run any problem and
there's no better example than this this
is the night of March 3rd this is the
first night he starts running his
simulations and he stops at 18 8 because
the Los Alamos guys come back that's the
memory location which he stops the
creation of life and they come to work
on the hydrogen bomb so you have this
trying to create life and trying to
destroy it on the same machine so I you
can probably tell I think Niels
baricelli was a true prophet and saw
things that that we still can't see as
clearly yet but he was interested in how
did the genetic language evolve and how
did you get these complex nucleotides
and he saw that as a digital that these
were digital codes and he called when
Washington Crick published a paper in
DNA nihlus he called DNA molecule shaped
numbers and so he runs all these
universes it's not diverse enough so he
runs multiple universes and allows
organisms to go back and forth between
three universes but he realizes no
matter how many mutations we make the
numbers will always remain numbers I'll
never become organisms you must not just
a genotype but a phenotype you have to
let these numbers go out in the world
and do something and that's what
software it did that suddenly codes
evolved that you know some guys helped
the code call visicalc evolve and it
could do spreadsheets and suddenly it
reproduced really well and was copied
and and cloned and and that's the world
we live in where these creatures in a
way have sort of become loose and he
sees how that you need to be able to
transmit code back and forth and let it
sort of operate like proteins and
so we very you know if you live there if
Barrett le was back with me at the world
today he'd see all his sort of ideas
come to life that if humans developed a
habit of transmitting computer programs
allowing a computer directed factory to
construct the machine needed for a
particular purpose which is it sort of a
technical definition of the Java
language or something like that that
would be the analog to the communication
methods among cells of various species
so and here he's talking about the that
the genetic code evolved as a language
used by primordial collector societies
of nucleotides and I think that I think
that is the key to the origins of life
but how do you explain these complex
polynomial tides it was very simple
nucleotides behaving like like ants or
honeybees going out to collect amino
acids and bring them back to the nest
and they developed this language to
coordinate you know collecting the the
nectar or all the things that ants go
out and gather and that's how you
develop that complexity and he always
made clear this wasn't he wasn't trying
to build models he wasn't doing this to
make things that looked like life he was
interested in allowing lifelike
processes to evolve his last paper
published what it would take for these
numerical organisms to develop a
language and technology of their own and
when I talked to Julian Bigelow before
he died he I asked him about Nils and he
said well baricelli was the only person
who really understood the path toward
genuine artificial intelligence at that
time but that real artificial
intelligence was something that would
evolve on its own within this digital
universe not be programmed or created
when I started digging around for all
this stuff in the basement of these old
buildings the Box turned up that had
nobody had looked at it was completely
covered in greasy teletype manuals on in
the bottom was a box that had the
complete source code and punch cards for
one of these digital universe
experiments and with it a note from the
engineer to mr. baricelli saying there
must be something about this code that
you
haven't explained yet and and that's
really what what drew Alan Turing and
what drew von Neumann was that the these
purely sequential codes can produce
results that that cannot be predicted
and that that's what makes it so
interesting von Neumann dies in February
1957 and immediately the Institute gets
rid of the whole project they tell
everybody to leave they most of them go
off to work for IBM von Neumann had
given Julian Bigelow a permanent
membership in the Institute and and
Bigelow was stubborn and said no I'm
staying I'm not gonna leave and they
realized they couldn't make him leave it
they'd have to give him a raise so he
lived there the whole rest of his life
making nine thousand dollars a year
raising three kids and all Von Neumanns
dreams of sort of a school of computer
science that would look at what these
machines could do came to an end and
that's the last entry in the log book
July 15 1958 12 midnight off Julian H
Bigelow so he had so much he wanted to
still do and remain so bitter that he
never went anywhere else he just
withdrew only gave one or two talks and
wrote a few papers a real tragedy so I'm
just gonna lead you through and I'm not
gonna read all this but these are one of
the rare published descriptions where he
talked about what what he saw the
problems and where they were going that
we were so limited in this machine that
he had designed was a numerical machine
built to answer this hydrogen bomb
question and it was terribly inefficient
use of the computational resources that
it was purely serial it could only do
what programmers could write in a series
of sequential steps and that's not the
way the real world works so in fact only
one thing is going on in the computer at
a time you have you know the Machine I'm
running these slides on is running
billions of cycles a second but only one
thing happening once so Julian it was
sort of a tragedy that we got stuck
in just this very simple model of
computing and he has I think it was a
very good insight this was really driven
by the programmers that that electronic
computers eat up instructions very
rapidly because they'll you know they'll
they're waiting for a billion
instructions a second and how are you
gonna write all those instructions so
programmers are forced you know you
think the computer is kept effectively
you try and keep it busier than the
programmer and highly recursive
conditional and repetitive routines are
used because they are notationally
efficient but not necessarily unique as
descriptions of real-world processes so
it's we're driven by that programmers
write these iterative routines because
that's how you can generate a whole lot
of instructions and still go home for
dinner at the end of the day and so
we're also limited in our in completely
julienne saw time in a very different
way that you could actually do computing
that looked at time not in this linear
way at all we've sort of now we would
call massively parallel computing or
backwards in time or forwards and and
we're so restricted in what we do and
then the fundamental problem was what
phenomena gave us was this address
matrix that everything has to have an
address a goodell address a girdle
number and so accomplishment of the
desired time sequential process on a
given computing apparatus turns out to
be largely a matter of specifying
sequences of addresses of items which
are interacting and that's what if you
go to any of these companies down here
that are writing software that's what
most of the men and women they are doing
they are just writing long lists of
addresses because everything has to have
an exact address or it crashes huge
waste of time so Bigelow says at the end
that you know entirely possible to build
computers that address through different
methods and the obvious one would be
template based address we do not just
say where something is you just have to
which is how biology addresses molecules
you don't know where the next protein is
you just say I want the next or the next
string of DNA that has a partial match
to this template
that is much more robust and
time-independent multiple things can be
happening at once and that we are living
now in the transition to a world where
that's what's starting to go on in the
digital universe if you look at what
Google is doing Facebook other
successful companies are starting to use
template based addressing it all the
things are there for that to be
absolutely viable as a way of writing
code we just aren't doing it yet and a
few people are so Bigelow he's there at
that world where and that's the window
they looked in the machine room where
what weird what we're doing with our you
know all our devices I mean we are on
one side and on the other side is all
this process to penalties but it's just
all it wants is instructions saying give
us instructions and we're tapping and
and connecting to friends and doing all
this stuff just trying to feed these
order codes with the instructions that
they want and this is just growing so
fast
what Bigelow said to us is it's the the
the main point tonight is that the
maniac the machine was called the
mathematical and numerical integrator
and computer didn't have anything like a
pulsar in it no clocks no pulsers no
nothing it was all of it a large system
of on and off binary gates no clock so
you had to have gates so one thing
happened after another
you don't need clocks you only need
counters there's a difference between a
counter and a clock time is not the
variable you keep track of the sequence
is what you keep track of and that's
enormous ly different from a clock the
clock keeps track of time and a modern
general-purpose computer keeps track of
events sequence is different from time
no time is there and that is the truth
the truth is that the digital world is
based on sequence and our world is based
on time and that's why there's this
disconnect because every year the chip
companies go to smaller scale masks and
things like that and we're getting we're
getting faster and faster there's no
limit to this to this
doesn't have a governor and it just
keeps going that so if you were in the
computer computational if you were one
of Barrett Shelley's organisms looking
through the glass at us we would be like
the guy in the opening film just be
slowing down just you know the cup of
tea would hardly be moving it would be
so slow
and it just in 50 years there's been
this huge disconnect it sort of ends
with a sort of different law now where
we live our moment is an eternity in
this computational world and this is a
book if you haven't read you have to
read because it's why again we're these
dark sad views of the future but this is
the future where everybody is just in
their room looking at the screen
ordering from Amazon and and in the
armchair there sits a swaddle lump of
flesh a woman about five feet high with
a face as white as a fungus never goes
outside and the machine stops so that's
one alternative and the other one is
that you know we don't know which way
it's gonna turn but that's the world
that steward is moving us into so
quickly right now with his new partner
George church this was a dinner in Los
Angeles who actually Stuart and Ryan
were in the next room with Danny Hillis
craig venter Jon Brockman Nathan
Myhrvold this was a meeting looking at
programming cells with computers as Oh
George Church made this statement after
dinner we can program these cells as if
they were an extension of the computer
which is true means Stuart's gonna do
that but from life's point of view I
think it might be going the other way if
you look at life life probably began
this is our fathers theory but with
metabolism that was then infected by
replicating parasites and the infected
host learned to adapt to the replicative
parasite and take advantage of it and we
got the modern system of replicating you
know we we sort of do the
Bigelow thing if we repeat ourselves
once we're analog creatures and once a
generation we repeat ourselves with a
digital code to correct the errors then
we go back to analog and then we have
children we go through this digital
phase and we have children now life is
very good at that life you know grass
will grow up in the in the worst you
know the place where nobody waters it
and I think it's actually the other way
that life is saying we can program these
computers as if they were an extension
of the cell if you look at any molecular
biology replication has been a huge
advantage to the organisms that
discovered it and computer replication
is really additive you can you can
reproduce yourself over the internet in
you know Stewart and George Church will
be sending genes back and forth between
here and Boston at the speed of light so
so from life's point of view in a way
that the the computer memory may just be
the next form the next sort of replicate
of parasite that then is take advantage
of in order to evolve new forms of
analog life and I think Stewart wants to
do that for all the right reasons
to bring back passenger pigeons and
Dodos and things like that but that's
the world we're in we're where that's
the growth in transistors if you follow
that grab that graph that's an on a log
scale when I last looked it was five or
six trillion transistors per second or
being added and they're all connected
through this address space so the last
thing you give you just an analogue
Fable back to my world as a boatbuilder
it's my daughter who's in the audience
the little little girl there then I
built kayaks which are frames so in the
North Pacific there were two different
approaches to building boats there were
people who lived in the islands with no
trees who built skin boats where they
put the frame of wood together and then
covered it and then there were people
who lived in the forest where who built
dugout canoes where there was so much
wood they had to build a boat by
removing wood and now in the world of
information
we're sort of I come from the world of
kayak building where I would I would
gather little pieces of information put
them together in a book but now we're
surrounded you know by so much
information we have to become dugout
canoe builders and actually remove
information to find the meaning and so
we're both so I'm from the kayak world
and my daughter Lauren there who works
for Code for America down the street is
of this world you know there's a rain
forest was raining information and that
so the the buzzword of last year was big
data I had to define it so I'll leave
you with my definition big data is what
happened when the cost of storing
information became less than the cost of
making the decision to throw it away and
that this world that Julian Bigelow and
you know brought to us is the world that
Leibniz imagined again in 1697 about the
time of friar bacon that's blindnesses
explanation of how the whole world is
digital and that if you understand once
and zeroes you can understand everything
and we're still at the works of
witnessed the birth of that world thanks
to all the people who will allow me to
go into their basements and save stuff
and don't throw it out the families who
let me dig through their papers and I
just feel lucky to have lived you know
been brought to that Institute with was
that's my sister Esther and me and our
older sister Katarina and our mother
Verena who was a is a group theorist who
met a physicist and they you know so
there we grew up in the middle of that
world and and and here we are and I
still have a little piece of that if you
want to write to me you can send me an
email because so a little tiny piece of
that universe that Bigelow created is
now my email account in that same
basement where they started but if you
send me if you even send me one sentence
it'll that email will be more memory
than the whole machine had that they
built and that's
that's it thank you
I see at hand well you got a gleeful
audience here and I must say what's the
equivalent of the Institute for Advanced
Study today says somebody named Esther
that's a very good question
I mean there are all sorts of
Institute's there's about six of them
that call themselves Institute for
Advanced Study there's one in Singapore
there's one in Dublin Ireland so it's
been a model that's been replicated but
in the perimeters I went to speak there
when they opened their new building they
put a hundred and sixty pure theoretical
physicists together as if they're
looking they're trying to find the new
Einstein but if you want to find
Einstein you'll find him at the Patent
Office filling out forms you won't find
him sorry to say I don't think you're
gonna find him at the Perimeter
Institute and so I I think we cannot say
I mean I think the important thing to
remember how the Institute was not the
work that was done there but that they
saved those persecuted people at a time
when it was a matter of life and death
so it's the people who are it's the
organizations that are going out of
their way to give jobs to people who
really need them and that goes for our
country as well as other countries but I
can't say there's one Institute that's
that's succeeding in that model so in
that sense they're weird byproduct of
Hitler they were not as he shook all of
Europe basically these guys sifted out
all the in a place to get the
intellectual property to to America the
same way we you know we're at risk of
doing the same thing now if we were not
careful
related questions from Kevin Kelly and
Danny and Kevin asked with their
alternative schemes that could have
birthed a different style of digital
universe and Danny LS were there other
divergent attempts to develop computing
that failed was this an evolutionary
process and one one or was it something
else no it was it was like so many
things I think in in business and life
and biology was I think a matter of luck
and circumstance that I think the
critical thing there was a von Neumann
had the right connect
he had the connections with the
government and the funding to make this
happen and you know one model there was
good it was sort of a winner-take-all
game and and his design became the
winner-take-all but the but the British
designs I think could have worked as
well or better Touring's design was in
some way though I did more interest to
poop out the British didn't throw any
money at it I mean they and they kept it
secret they the the British all the
Colossus work was was held under the
Official Secrets Act until like 1973 so
the British people who wanted to build
computers had to come to America and
work for American companies but no
excessive secrecy homophobia they and
the Alan Turing's life and and then you
know and when I was researching this
book I found a sort of smoking gun which
was there was a very successful company
was at the time was much more successful
computing than IBM was the Eckert
Lockley electronic control company and
they built a machine called UNIVAC which
had a different model of memory it
didn't have the von Neumann address
space model it had the linear delay line
memory but it worked quite well wasn't
fast enough to do hydrogen bombs but it
was fast enough to do most of the normal
things that people in normal business
needed and they were building a business
machine and they had an order but they
needed orders they didn't have you know
deep pockets and they had an order for
three machines from from the government
and I found a document where their
security cleanliness was called into
question and they lost their contract
now you don't know how or why those
contracts were pulled but it effectively
killed their company and the shell of it
went to Remington Rand and sort of gave
us the world we live in but but at one
time if you were betting money you would
put your money on univac not IBM so I
don't know it runs deep and kills
everything well it's just it is true
that it wasn't and I think the same is
true of telephones and I mean so many
other of our inventions did not go
necessarily to the best
and they went to the so the Bigelow
theory is bit early hanging on and he's
got this different notion that sequence
instead of clock instead of time could
that have been deployed earlier than it
was by Google and Facebook and the
internet yes I mean that's the tragedy
is that Bigelow didn't go off to I mean
when you look through his papers which
were just in boxes he has all these
invitations oh please come to IBM come
to SR Stanford Research Institute here
they were s turns were trying to get him
to UCLA you know to start a computer
science department there he could have
gone to any of these places and and
realized some of his ideas but that
stubborn bitterness kept and there were
family reasons his wife was very ill
health and he didn't want to leave but
it was trying to hire him away and were
they aware of his value in trying to you
know everybody I mean at that time
Julian Bigelow was the this master who
had brought this world into existence
and he had his idiosyncrasies he
suffered depression and so on but they
but he was in demand I mean he could
have gone anywhere and so but he said
you know fun women gave me a permanent
membership here and I'm sticking to it
and it's it's a house he regarded in
Princeton now well he was regarded
rather poorly but the we have a there's
a new director at this Institute who has
completely taken out has formally
apologized to the family on behalf of
his pre because why that something
happened at his funeral they didn't
treat him right or something maybe why I
mean you know when he died what happened
at Princeton when well when he died we
tried to have a the family had a
memorial service at the Quaker
meetinghouse
was across these woods from the
Institute and then Freeman our Father
tried tried to and I tried to have a
reception in the main hall a student the
administration said no he's not he's
still unwelcome and and that changed in
10 years that's because of your book
because yeah and because of look who's
on their board I mean
Charles Simoni Eric Schmidt Jeff Bezos
Nathan Myhrvold Mirena von Neumann I
mean you know it's it's it's time to
bury that hatchet and in fact I go to
Princeton tomorrow and they are
celebrating his centenary and if and the
other side of the family is donating the
paper
these papers to the okay so there's a
happy ending but it's sad that this you
know that this could not have been
resolved 40 years ago Pierre more assess
what part did women play in the early
days the women appear in the slides it
says there's the Clara funnyman she
being secretarial or she doing so she
was writing real Bob code and and the
you know the the prevailing view which
again I've tried to counter is that the
you know one of the views has been all
the women just did arithmetic they they
didn't they wrote the codes which is a
lot of clerical work but they didn't
they didn't need to understand the
physics but if you read Clarys private
letters back and forth to Johnny she's
deeply involved in the physics she's
talkin Z's calculations would be looking
at one hydrogen bomb problem for six
weeks it might be running and you have
to look at what's what's happening with
the neutron capture the fish and so on
and modify your parameters and your mesh
size ask the physics progresses and she
was fully familiar with that and there's
an interesting reason why I think why
she was so good at it because when the
war started everybody wanted to work in
the war effort she got a job at the
population Research Institute in
Princeton modeling populations of what
would happen to Europe you know even
questions like how how low could the
Jewish population go and still recover
things like that and that's exactly
that's nuclear physics it's looking at
at reproduction what critical mass
population density just taking censuses
if you look at the language of Monte
Carlo it's they take a census at every
time step and that's and then and as to
women there were many other women the
woman who really ran physically ran the
the person who when they had problems
that perplexed everybody else they went
to Hedy Selberg who was Otley cell
Berg's
wife who hadn't been a physics teacher
and also lost all her family in the
concentration camps she escaped to
Scandinavia Marriott Lisa L Bergen and
couldn't wasn't allowed to teach science
in New Jersey school so fine diamon gave
her a job and she she ran that machine
and understood it to a degree that
nobody else did
so before computers were machines
computers were people mostly women why I
think they were available and they were
very good at it they were meticulous and
they weren't all women if you actually
look at the photographs of like the WPA
ran these big numerical computation
projects during the 1930s they tend to
be mostly women and black men figure
that out well now so Monte Carlo is
pretty interesting as stand-alones
standard alums invention do you want to
tell the story of how he invented it
Myka well I'm one of his friends told me
he was a combination of the most
intelligent and laziest person he had
ever met so he had brilliant ideas but
he didn't like to do the hard work of
executing and and and he left us on you
could see the right it looked like Osama
switch shut down they designed the bomb
the war had been won it would be over so
he got a job teaching at USC and almost
immediately came down with viral
encephalitis a terrible brain infection
almost died we had to open up his skull
to let the pressure out and they didn't
really understand that at that time I
said the three medieval thing well we're
gonna cut a hole in your skull better
for the best right and and the doctors
told him to we had to recuperate for six
and they told him to stop thinking
you got a hole in your head don't do
anything it'll leak out there and so his
but he'd been you know working on all
these neutron multiplication problems
these branching processes which were the
heart of what they were trying to do in
Los Alamos and they didn't have the
computer power to do them in brute force
analytic so he don't go something he
started playing solitaire play solitaire
over here but then he started thinking
about how could I predict how a
solitaire game is gonna turn out
mathematically because everything heats
I you know whoever as a mathematician we
grew up with them because they see
everything as a mathematical problem how
can you predict a car you know and then
he realized that a much better way to
get the answer was just play a hundred
solitaire games and and sample it and
that was the origin of Monte Carlos was
effectively a way of of taking a sort of
random walk through a undefined space
and coming back with a sample of what
and it was immediately effective it
immediately solved these bomb problems
it's used and you know it's probably the
most successful algorithm ever there was
a happy was it was it was a way of
playing it was a way of gambling and
finding the answer and and but you
needed interesting was to do Maya Carla
you needed random numbers so there was a
great shortage of random numbers they
couldn't get enough random numbers and
so the guys that ran in you can't make
this up in Santa Monica they published a
book of a million random digits to do
money problem which you can still buy
and the preface says you know due to the
nature of this book we did not proofread
this
[Laughter]
and if there's some non-random numbers
don't sue us right we didn't really look
now and now real hackers have studied
this book and actually they're not truly
random it's a little bit off so how much
do you lose in Montecarlo if you're if
you're not quite a true random you don't
you don't lose that much but it it can
become important you know it's like
cryptography that a little bit of
weakness can be dangerous so it's
goddamn article low player you leave
what the sense I get from some of your
texts is that Montecarlo discovered it
was beginning to approximate how things
happen in the world yeah that's what's
that's this interesting twist it's sort
of like what happened in biology you
know that we used to think I mean in the
old days sort of mathematicians if you
gave them long enough they would come up
with a true formula you know Newton
style for the way things really were and
you could calculate it exactly this is
this beautiful platonic kind of world
and then quantum physics came along and
showed us that well the real world
really isn't that way the real at its
heart the real world is not billiard
balls it's statistical noise and and
it's probabilistic and and Monte Carlo
is this probabilistic simulation but in
reality Monte Carlo is closer to the way
the world really is and this pure ideal
that people had hoped for so I think
that's one reason Monte Carlo has been
so effective because it's the way the
world really is so to come back to the
point in your title and the digital
universe which we now occupy at least
part time and the physical biological
universe which we occupy a part time are
running at different rates say more
about that well it's something we've
never seen before and we have no idea
how it will end up and you have to
remember these numbers are living in
their own world on the other side of
that mirror that glass and they're
eventually going to discover what Julian
Bigelow was talking about you know
they're going to realize you know if if
the cells in the
computer you know I haven't done
anything for a hundred billion cycles
yeah well I haven't done I think 110
billion cycles you know why don't we do
something about that and and in a way
that's what cloud computing is I mean
all these things that are suddenly
happening and then cloud computing is
just a way of more efficiently using the
resources so the weight between these
steps is not is great that you're not
waiting you know computer if I don't
have an instruction for it the cloud
says well here's some instructions work
on this and everything is effective
that's why again why Gutwein amazon's
cloud business is the most successful
thing they've done because they're
they're building you know the Bigalow
the the classic computer that runs it at
point zero zero zero zero zero one
percent efficiency maybe they're getting
it up to 1 percent or 2 percent and but
we know that in biology things are are
much more efficient and and we're that
that's sort of avoiding your question
but the question is once evolution has
been sort of an arms race for organisms
against each other and once they start
playing that out in what you're trying
to do letting you know because what
you're going to run into with these
passenger pigeons that to do the actual
animal husbandry which is the other side
of it I mean which you talk about in
your talk it's what I think if you
haven't seen Stewart's talk watch it
come back to you have to find a mother
and father regular pigeon and you have
to give them an egg and they you still
have to hatch a real egg to get this
supposedly passenger pigeon back and all
that takes some time you have to hatch
eggs and wait and you're gonna find that
most of them are not going to turn out I
mean you know the pigeon is gonna die or
it's not gonna live so it's inevitably
it will be much to your benefit to do
what the bomb people didn't start
simulating some of this in the
computational world to predict whether
the genome is going to be viable and
right and and then then suddenly you you
know we are in this world where
evolution is is gonna be running on the
faster so we the larval form of digital
organisms or
the larval form of biological organisms
I mean I think you hope that it ends up
with sort of both the way the way things
have worked a lot in the real world were
where you end up with a symbiosis that
that is that really possible with this
rate difference because it's not only
that things go in a way so much faster
in the digital world but it's not
constantly faster it's accelerating ly
faster until a biological world is not
accelerating at all yeah that's the
explosive part we don't we don't know
where that's gonna go we just have no
clue we just hope that they in their
world they still need us to take care of
them and you know the other but I tell I
love these books that look at the dark
outcomes and the other one is ape and
essence which also a set here in
California where after nuclear war
Huxley almost yeah oh it's actually
nobody knows about it because he was so
famous for for his other books but but
there he's because over the question of
well it once replication becomes
unreliable Society will disintegrate and
so the the people from New Zealand show
up 100 years after nuclear war and they
land in Los Angeles which is run by
baboons the the evolution is starting to
run backwards but the scarier thing is
is what if replication becomes perfect
which is what what we have with
computers we have perfect replication
and we you don't want that in biology I
mean like a worst nightmare I think the
worst of that book of random numbers
that it can you you can but will people
want to you know I mean I think it's a
scarier thing to think about what if
what if people can get exactly the
offspring they want and well this is
yeah this is Gregory Bateson sold
worried that that pure intention purely
realized this all is pathological
worry about that well another book
that although sexually wrote is called
time must have a stop and alas we must
have a stop thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
you